yes this is definitely not safe for work
needed on a school shape that you get on
a spook shape then you get on a school
shake what's he doing my school said
something Kyle hooked it up is this man
mad huh oh he's okay how do these pants
prevent it Czech Republic Chainsaw
Massacre huh the secret superevil
survival is down to the pump underneath
the green layer there are eight tightly
packed layers of plastic fibers the
plastic called synthetic aromatic
polyamide or aramid for short aramid's
are very long straight molecules and
they are first made by putting them into
a solution in which they're all randomly
oriented in different directions they're
then spun and ask their spun a little
bit like wool the molecules start to
write alongside one another cross links
start to form between these long
molecules forming really strong fibers
in fact the pulling or the tensile
strength of the Hermes can be over eight
times that of steel wire making them
very difficult to break so now the
canyon hit the lift the fibers don't
break but instead get pulled up into the
chainsaw mechanism they end up jamming
the sprockets of the turning wheel
stopping the chain in less than one
revolution
I love provel because he has full faith
in the chemistry and he has proven these
really do work and while Pavel heads out
to buy a new pair of pants we move on to
number 18
Jill ciao